[موسيقى]
تدرب المنتخب الفرنسي لكره القدم يوم
الاثنين في مقره التدريب في كلير فونتان
بفرنسا ضمن استعداداته للدفاع عن لقبه في
كاس العالم لكره القدم في قطر قبل ايام
اعلن المدرب جديد قائمه من 25 لاعبا
سيمثلون فرنسا ومنذ ذلك الحين التحق
لاعبان اخرا بالمنتخب ويتعلق الامر
بماركوستورام مهاجم بروسيا مونشنغلادباخ
الالماني الذي اصبح اللاعب السادس
والعشرين في القائمه ومدافع موناكو اكثر
ديساسي الذي استدعي للتعويض عن تراث
المصادقه ومن المقرر ان يسافر منتخب فرنسا
الى الدوله الخليجيه يوم الاربعاء اي
اسبوعا قبل خوض اولى مبارياته في
المونديال
فتره تحضيره
السبت البدنيه
سنسافر يوم الاربعاء
وانطلاقا من يوم الخميس
سنبدا الاستعدادات لمباراه يوم الثلاثاء
سنحاول اخذ كل لاعب على حده
والعمل معه
بحسب اليقته البدنيه
قبل المشاركه
في التدريبات الجماعي
ضد استراليا ضمن المجموعه الرابعه التي
تضم ايضا تونس والدنمارك
[تصفيق]